when you are part of the Neo-Nazi
movement and you and you stand up in the
morning when you drink your first tea
and you hate you hate all day and uh and
you listen to music and you hang around
with comrades who all hate hate is just
part of your life every every second
[Music]
I was born in Lubeck it's a small town
uh nearby Hamburg my parents are quite
wealthy
I I didn't lack anything in my in my
young life and I had a I had a good
childhood I didn't I didn't get any
violence from my parents or was abuse or
anything and uh yeah going to school and
everything was running very fine
until my father decided that we're
moving from uh from lübeck that we're
moving up to Newcastle I was 10 years
old at that time
and uh that was a that was quite a shock
for me as a 10 year old I didn't even
know where England is or what Newcastle
is and I didn't speak one word in
English on the way to the school the
first uh the first person spit on me and
I arrived in the class and somebody just
threw out my uh my stuff
I was I was like brought in into the
class and just everybody looked at me
like
that's a German they never seen a German
before
and they're um yeah they called me a
Nazi
um crowd and Fritz and whatever you guys
call Germans and uh I know I didn't
understand it I never heard the word
Nazi before or anything I didn't know
about it my parents picked me up from
school and I was crying I said I want to
go back to Germany I hate it here I
don't understand anybody I don't have
any friends
that's the first time in my life that I
was a there was a feeling being alone
but I started I started to learn English
I had no choice after maybe six months I
could speak English better than now here
I forgot a lot now
and it took a long time to
um to show I'm not a nazia we didn't
know my parents are not neo-nazis or
anything but it took like one year for
the first person to um
to to come to my house I didn't speak
German anymore I only spoke English and
uh yeah I was now 14 years old we stayed
like for four years and then my parents
decided to go back to Germany
um this time I just didn't cry just
anymore I I was in I was very angry and
very violent like throwing doors and
just shouting at my parents I want to
stay in Newcastle yeah I was very proud
I was called the German majority in
Newcastle and I was very proud of it
and yeah but I had no choice 14 years
old had to move back with my uh with my
parents
how did you kind of first make contact
with with the Neo-Nazi groups I'm now 15
15 and a half years old and I was a I
was just just an angry angry lad uh just
starting to hate everything like I hated
school I hated Society
and uh and we came to music to angry
music
it's a racial white power music and
these people
um they sing about
um they sing a lot of about a lot of
people they hate everybody like Jewish
people Muslims like
um uh like gay people like every
Democrat like police and Justice and
every Democrat and they hate everybody
in the music they can sing about
everybody I had the feeling they're
talking directly to me and saying Philip
remember you belong to the best people
in the world you are an Aryan you belong
to the one or two percent on this Earth
who are the best people in the world you
should be ruling this world it's about
white power it's about saving your
um it's about saving your race and it's
uh when you come to us you will become
part of our big family yeah
um we're the good ones we are fighting
for Europe
and this music
um was the first time in two years at
that point who said to me I'm a I'm a
good person
yeah my parents forgot to say this to me
school forgot to say this to me and this
white power music did this I know this
is very difficult to say but
um right right wing movement works works
for a short time yeah if it wouldn't
work it would have been disappeared
I had this anger in me and then it just
needed a sort of small light like for me
to explode
so I became very violent at school and
uh and on the
when it was a schoolyard I found some
other guys that were very angry as well
we just started to hang around like five
six seven guys
and uh we um we didn't want to belong to
society anymore yeah we said well we
don't want to be a part we don't want to
wear your clothes we don't want to wear
you
um whatever you wear we don't want to
listen to You music and we don't want to
be part of your Society
and then some older comrades they heard
oh there are these young guys like
hanging around and they they are in no
no movement yeah they're just hanging
around but and they said well
just on the weekend just just come to
our Pub and then uh we buy you a beer
and we have a barbecue and and then and
then the politics came like we first
um did it on a friendship basis yeah
just yeah just putting some ties some
some loose ties and then when you start
to hang around you say well well yeah
you take that music you listen to that
here's a t-shirt here's like or or next
weekend we're traveling to Berlin
there's a there's a something from our
right wing party for a short time they
gave us the feeling
um of seeing us I don't know how you say
it in English like all right I see you
guys you are angry you can be part of us
of our movement I wanted to believe and
I was scared as a 16 or 17 year old to
like to to talk against the older
comrades yeah I wanted to be part of
their family and their group and that
was all I had at that time
um a big role all played at that time
that were a Neo-Nazi concerts just like
meeting up with 500 or a thousand people
just like sick hiling in the concert and
that sort of gives you a feeling
um you're Ultra strong like hanging
around with a thousand yeah Lads and
just uh just hating and just shouting at
this music you think you're unbeatable
yeah you think you're very important and
and that was the thing that worked very
well at my uh at this point
I don't know how to say it in English
but but even but even the evil can have
Charisma yeah it is uh and nobody is all
day long evil yeah they can be also a
good friend but they are still very
violent and uh and and and and
Spread spread this hate
obviously you mentioned your family and
how are they reacting to this
my parents thought all right this is
just just like a short phase I don't
know yeah can you it's just like a short
phase and uh
and it will grow out yeah all right he's
now a little bit violent and uh but
everything will be sorted out in one or
two years and they they just looked away
I think they didn't want to see it I put
a swastika a flag in my in my uh in my
in my room and my mom just came in and
just put it down and just uh just um
just hid it from me and I just searched
the house and I put it back on and my
mother put it back off they just didn't
talk with us our family just didn't sit
down and talk and and at what one point
I didn't want to talk anymore as soon as
I had these friends I just didn't want
to talk with my parents anymore as soon
as they asked me something I just said
[__] off
what kind of is expected of you if
you're to join to join this group
it is expected from you that you visit
demonstrations that you put some power
into the movement they um they want to
rewrite history they say we have a
different view on History we have
different facts they have
um they have like books for themselves
where they say we are the victims we are
not we are not the aggressor but there
are some things that um that every group
thinks of it's the first point it is
racism that's the easiest thing
um to live out you don't have to have a
good school education you have to study
or anything ever you can just put people
into uh yeah into races and just say
well I belong to the best and you're you
don't you're you're you belong to
somebody
um worthless
um that's that's very easy so race
racism was everywhere
um it belongs
um the anti-Semitism
um like hating uh Jewish people and
saying uh Jewish people are uh
are um are like directing the world
and of course a new thing which came up
in the last 10 15 years is uh is the
hate against Muslims uh coming to Europe
and uh uh like these groups say like
they're trying to uh to force out
Christianity most of the people in the
Neo-Nazi scene are looking for a new
fuhrer uh like uh like a strong strong
man isn't allowed to be a woman yeah for
a neo-nazis so they're looking for a
strong man like Germany you say we have
to we need a little Hitler yeah
and would you I know like comrades
racially abused people on the street in
public or was it all kind of done in
secret
yeah sometimes people think like
neo-nazis go out on the street and they
just hate hate like everybody they see
yeah then that that doesn't work but of
course when when we were as a group in
in tune then
um
weird pick like on
on some some some guys when when we're
in a group and we had shouted them uh
um racial things and looking for a fight
that was normal life
started for me being violent just
it sounds maybe maybe strange but yeah
just fighting with fists and yeah just
just like just some bruises and uh you
you get better at violence just like you
get better when you train to ride a
bicycle or go swimming you you you just
become better at it and uh and you start
to to organize weapons like using a
knife and then I organized my my uh my
first gun and uh
I was stabbed stabbed stabbed down when
I was 17 just running around as well
like stubbing people at the beginning
where I came into this group and we felt
very strong and uh and I thought I was
part of something very big I was yeah I
was I was growing and now now the people
started to fear me
so
um yeah I was maybe not happy but I felt
the first time after many years being
part of something when you were part of
the Neo-Nazi movement
um and you and you stand up in the
morning when you drink your first tea
and you hate you hate all day
and uh and you listen to music and you
hang around with comrades who all hate
hate is just part of your life every
every second
um and um the the first thing you lose
is like empathy for people yeah I didn't
feel anything for for human beings
anymore
so it was very easy for me like to be
violent at them because I didn't see
them as human beings
um and then it just got more and more
like
um to the point I was shooting at people
for
for me for uh
yeah to kill them
and you mentioned like actively shooting
at people did you ever see anybody die
um
out of I'm I I founded a i founded a
comrade group yeah I was I was a leader
of a very well-known comedy group in
Germany and uh
and these comrades at a at a New Year's
Eve
um they uh they killed somebody and they
are in their apartment I wasn't there
but they were my boys at that at that
time
um but I wasn't part of it but I was
like very nearby
yeah that was very uh very terrible when
they when they killed somebody
I was just a little bit shocked at how
how cold how cold blooded they did it
yeah they just they just didn't see a
human being there
um on this night they they uh
um somebody who visited them they cut
his throat
and uh they were talking about it like
like they they stumped like on an on an
aunt on a on the floor or something
um
that was uh that was the first time for
me to think about is this the right
movement yeah are these the right people
I'm hanging around with
um but it still took a while to to go
out of that movement but I was shocked
how cold-blooded it was
did you have any guilty conscience about
what you were doing
at that point no
um
um all the years I was I was in this
movement I always thought I was I was
right
um
um when you are in these groups you
start to lie to yourself
yeah you think you are the good one but
inside I knew we are the bad ones
and um but um
I lied to myself and I thought we are
doing everything right and uh and all
all extremists
um say um we are the victims we we only
fight back yeah we fight back to the to
the police to the democracy and we are
the victims so yeah I thought I was
always right
can you talk about your kind of Rise
through the the ranks
we we always prepared ourselves
um in the belief that one day we will
arise and take over a democratic
structures like taking over
um the the council the mayor's office
and the police stations in order to do
this on this day when we arise we need
weapons and we have to be prepared
um and this was uh this was quite uh
quite easy in a short time
um to like unite
um like 30 40 50 people uh really on the
radical side to to prepare for uh for
Civil War in Germany
um all the time I was active in this
movement I I
um I always bought weapons uh when I was
18 or 19 years old I bought my first
Kalashnikov on a AK-47
um I had many
um uh machine guns from the second world
war which we bought from old veterans
and uh
um we we bought a punch of house you
know like like a rocket launcher
um some hand grenades and everything we
just
um we made like deposits in the in the
woods yeah like like a prepper but we
also planned
um attacks on like uh
um like um I don't know the antifa the
anti-fascist scene or uh or in uh some
lefties how we called it I don't know uh
um so we had fights with them just
taking them when we see them on the
streets we we waited around corners
attacking them
um so violence was powered like like
others
go once a week like out for dinner or
something we just planned violence
were there any points where you were
arrested during this time
yeah I was arrested a lot of times of
course had a lot of police raids
um at my house I was pulled out of the I
don't know if you have a like Police
SWAT or Special Forces like they raided
like my car and pulled me out with guns
and uh
so yeah I had a lot of trouble with
police but I was I was arrested and I
was I was out on probation I don't know
I think probation for 16 years can you
imagine yeah I I had a probation next to
another probation I like 16 years
probation I was arrested the first time
when I was uh 33 I had my first prison
time
and had you seen anyone
leave the far right movement and if so
how were they treated for leaving
well all I had in my life was I didn't
have any contact with my family just one
or once or twice a year just calling
them for Christmas yeah and just saying
yeah hello and as a young lad this
movement told me come to us yeah we're
the good ones here's family we see you
and we'll we'll take care of you and all
these good things
but the older I got
um
I looked around to the comrades and uh
and to be honest there were a lot of
people within this movement
um they were not socialized at all they
didn't go to work yeah they uh they
couldn't live a life they were full of
uh full of debt with their money yeah
and uh just just had just had enormous
social problems what I thought is is the
is the it's the right life and I was I
was promoting but it just it just made
me very unhappy and
um and I became like uh I fell into a
sort of depression
um living this life
I didn't have any friends outside this
movement I only had this group
so when when you decide to to go out of
the National Socialist movement
then you lose everything
um
you are called very quickly a traitor I
think a traitor
um and um and there and and their the
aggression from the group will come
towards you
and how was it for you leaving
um
I sort of lied to them yeah as you said
um I
um I I don't feel so good and I I need a
break sort of yeah yeah I'm still
fighting and I need a break and uh even
even that is for many of the comics like
they said why how you you you need a
break fighting for your race yeah what
is this so they already talked behind
your back
um but I'm I did it I did it very slowly
going out of it yeah I just
um I lied to them and then at one point
I said all right I'm out and I'm doing
something else but we'll stay friends
yeah that's the way I choose
um there are many ways to do it I think
the best way is just to go and just move
move somewhere else but that everybody
has to decide that for themselves
you know when you have been an outlaw
for 15 years and you're outside of
society in Germany when you are a new or
Nazi in Germany you are not part of
society most of the people in Germany
just hate you for being a Neo-Nazi
and there were a lot of articles about
me and the internet and the television
and everything and
going out of that group I was scared
um of
is society giving me a chance again yeah
if I if I want to change
um will people uh give me their hand
again am I is it allowed for me to be
loved again or to love somebody and to
take part in a normal society Society
life and and will people believe me it's
a it's a question
um till today maybe somebody from your
team will sit here and say once the Nazi
always a Nazi or something
um all these big questions was something
which uh which made me um think and uh I
was really scared of changing
because of all these questions
I think you cannot change your life
overnight it is not like uh it is
everybody who is who has changed in
their life they know that's a that's a
journey
my National Socialist
um view on the world and my thinking
died over many years yeah
um and I think the best way like it
worked I think from my point of view is
like
um to meet people
yeah not just to read books or study or
anything you have to meet people from
different countries from different
beliefs so you can so you can
lose your uh your racial view your view
uh your hate your view like on the world
and uh
I knew I needed professional help
um because of this life I lived so long
in this movement and uh yeah I went to
the prison psychiatric and uh and I
asked him for help I said I think I'm a
loony and I I destroyed my life and uh
and I need help I think it's a
superpower for everybody out there to
ask for help that's a absolute
superpower
and um
and he said yeah all right I will work
with you I was uh sentenced to three
years in prison and he worked with me uh
on my uh on My Views and on my uh
handling strategies
and I was very thankful for uh for this
help in prison I became a Buddhist in
prison
and uh yeah that was very important to
to get like professional help that was
very important
were you ashamed of your past
yeah of course
when I really started to like when I
stepped out
um that was the first time I I was
thinking about what I did to people like
um when you when you realize when you
are mid 30
and uh and you realize the last 20 years
um
you just you only destroyed lives
from these 20 years there's not one
person who will say or all right that's
good that I met Philip you just
have
um
bad influence on everything on people
and on society then when I was on prison
and I and I approached this change and I
wanted to change I was so mad at myself
that the first half year in prison like
I put a towel on my prison mirror
because I couldn't look
um I I didn't want to see my face
because I hated myself so much
um then in prison I lost uh the first
time in my life I lost the uh
uh I lost the idea of wanting to live
like maybe like it's time to die like
thinking about committing suicide like
um that's
um
that's uh
that's very hard to
to
um to find yourself thinking about
um committing suicide
and the first questions uh when I went
to this uh psychiatric
was the
is it all right for me to be loved again
yeah for because I did these things is
it is it all right for me to come back
to society and he said when you want to
stop hating when you want to stop being
violent
and hating foreigners or hating people
then it's your right to change and then
do it for yourself don't do it for
anybody else I use the time in prison to
be mad at myself and hating myself and
then I left this uh
this feeling being guilty behind me
I I was angry at me I I apologize to my
victims and I
um I left it behind me now
how old were you when you were released
from prison
um I was
38 38 when I was raised from prison yeah
when I now think about it was like 15
Wasted Years really I uh I destroyed the
lives of my victims I destroyed the the
the the families of my victims I
destroyed my family I destroyed my life
there's nothing good about these 15
years I just just ate myself or for
living this life
um maybe in the beginning when I was a
young guy
that that we were hanging around yeah
for a short time
um I had this feeling there was there
was like the family feeling but this
this didn't even hold for six months so
there was really nothing nothing good
about living this life it was just full
with hate and violence
from that point how did you take the
steps to rebuild your life to where you
are now
yeah I I was very thankful and I'm still
thankful for my parents and my uh my
sister and my brother-in-law
um who um who took me back into the
family without
um without any suspicion against me and
uh
and I came out of prison and I started
with zero friends yeah I just I just
didn't
um I just put all the contacts away I
was not available for anybody and I
moved back to my old city to Lubeck and
I started just with zero friends and uh
then I started to uh to talk about my
life at YouTube and uh
and I started to go out to do Sports
again and I met some people and uh and
they said well all right I'll give you a
chance just like and then uh now six
years later I have a I'm going to get
married this Summer and uh
and um I have a very good friends now
around me and I enjoy my new life to the
fullest
the main what's the main thing you would
want people to take away from hearing
your story
um it can happen to everybody it is not
like it's not not only poor people
radicalize or or people
um in in Muslim communities or in or in
like worker families or everything it
can happen to everybody it's all right
to be angry it's all right just not
everybody fits in into this one system
school there are times where where you
just have to be a friend just be there
yeah just not not leave anybody behind
and don't just say all right my kids and
just let them alone and your problems
are not so bad just listen to them be
aware and just just give some love I
think if I would have had this I
wouldn't have radicalized myself
[Music]
foreign
there was a guy sitting on the train
opposite with his wife and his two kids
and he had a Crystal Palace lapel badge
just a little badge on his jacket
the guy saw it he lent the cross and he
punched the bloke squarely in the face
and then hit him three more times in
front of his wife and his two kids